[Musique]
à toi là-bas c'est très difficile d'y
arriver juste en face à parfois j'étais
chez moi alors tu es qui commence à
aller un invité qui vous propose de
s'échapper
[Musique]
[Rires]
voilà
[Musique]
alors pour sa douche encore ah oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour toujours à beaune et à utiliser des
voitures a pas dit à moi elles vont te
dire prêcher son cerveau entendu
mais la pratique si on avait dit
la première question
c'est vraiment ça normalement c'est pas
mal dieu d'accord et ensuite ça
paraissait 3 est ce qu'on pourra
s'hydrater non n'importe quoi oui on
pourra s'hydrater pendant les pubs
rencontre
dote d'un nouveau vote à nos abonnés
ouais
thibault d'ayew
c'est continue franchement c'est soit
que ces swag mais là ça va
professeur de dormir
[Musique]